the function f of x is defined as f of x
is equal to 49 minus x squared find the
value of f of 5. so whenever you're
dealing with a function you take your
input in this case our input is going to
be our 5 we input it into our little
function box and we need to get our
output
and they define the function box years
whatever your input is take that square
it and then subtract it from 49. so f of
5 f of 5 every time i see an x here
since f of x is equal to this every time
i see an x i would replace it with the
input so f of 5 is going to be equal to
49 minus instead of writing x squared i
would write 5 squared so this is equal
to 49 minus 25 and 49 minus 25 is equal
to 24
and we are done